Speaker 1: As we continue to follow the work
of the Jan. six House Investigation Committee
Special Select Committee, it is starting to
reach further and further and further into
MAGA land.
And the news now is that MyPillow CEO Mike
Lindell says his phone records have been subpoenaed
by the House Committee.
It is now reaching pillow.
MyPillow CEO Mike Lindell says his phone records
have been subpoenaed by the House Committee
investigating the Jan. six riot at the Capitol.
I wasn't there on Jan. six, then.
Yes, they did subpoena my phone records, but
we filed a complaint for declaratory and injunctive
relief against the committee and Verizon to
completely invalidate this corrupt subpoena.
Lindell said in a text message to CNBC.
The revelation came after CNBC reported last
month that Lindell has spent $25 million since
Election Day 2020 to push false claims of
election fraud.
We know that pillow was at the White House
in that very, very crazy period during which
they were trying to come up with any way to
steal this election from the guy who actually
won it.
Joe Biden and MyPillow CEO Mike Lindell, known
to many of us lovingly as Mike Pillow or Just
Pillow, is now embroiled in this investigation.
Meanwhile, Pillow does seem to be losing confidence
that he's going to get.
Donald Trump reinstated, you know, all of
2020 and even 2012, I'm sorry, the end of
2020 and all of 2021.
He kept saying Trump's going to be back by
January, March, April, by Thanksgiving, by
the end of the year.
He was asked just a couple of days ago by
right wing host Eric Me.
Taxes, I'm sorry, taxes Metaxas.
If Joe Biden will be out by the end of 2022
and pillow is not sounding as confident anymore.
Take a listen to this.
Speaker 2: I'm talking right now to our friend,
Mike Lindell.
Mike, do you have confidence before we go
into these five things you mentioned one and
two.
Do you believe that in this calendar year
of 2022 are Biden will leave office?
All right.
You know, they'd be subjective, I pray for
that.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Now, listen, I'm praying against it.
So the prayer cancels out and I guess we'll
have to go with the courts or something like
that.
This is the least optimistic that pillow has
been.
And even in his interview with me, he was
insisting It's all going to happen.
It's all going to happen.
So a deflated Mike pillow here is Mike Pillow.
Also, this just a couple of days ago saying
his new thing is trying to get different voting
locales to change the voting machines that
they use on his recommendations.
Like, Dude, you make pillows, not voting machines.
Speaker 2: Oh, we're doing this and what we're
doing, we have teams, all these grassroots.
They will be approached, by the
Speaker 1: way I love is that a Minnesota
accent, grass roots?
That is just that I am.
I think I'm going to adopt that.
I like that
Speaker 2: change their county commissioners
who make the decisions whether to use dominion
or isn't as hard.
They're all the same.
Yeah, OK.
They also can make the decision to not use
the machines.
Remember, all the machines are defective.
Everybody is defective.
It's like bad brakes on your car.
Speaker 1: I want to remind you because it's
important to stay in compliance on YouTube.
It is not true that all voting machines used
in 2020 are defective.
There is no evidence of that.
Speaker 2: They don't work for what they were
intended to.
If you're a county commissioner out there
right now, you know what you can say bye bye
machines.
You know, remember we the public paid for
those machines.
The American people paid for those machines.
And you know what?
We don't want them anymore.
I don't care if you're a Democrat or a Republican.
You go to these county circuits.
We're doing it and saying, Hey, we don't want
these machines.
We have a great replacement is 50 times cheaper,
whatever it is.
And there's the technology.
And you know what?
It works.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
So there it is now.
As crazy as it is to take voting machine recommendations
from a pillow guy.
There are probably some county commissioners
who will do it.
And so we've got to be watching
out
for that.